bonsoir à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct ce soir sur rtl france christophe
alévêque je me tourne d'abord vers vous
vous êtes humoristes vous attendrir
pouvoir rejouer dès le 15 décembre
et comment est ce que vous avez pris les
annonces du premier ministre très mal
comme un petit enfant de 12 ans ont pu
ni puni par les qui sait pas pourquoi il
est puni donc tout a été fait dans les
théâtres pour que ça fonctionne j'ai moi
même joué dans des salles où les gens et
pas ce qu'est notre métier nous dans les
théâtres c'est d'accueillir les gens et
notre profession donc on les a
accueillis ils sont lavés les mains en
entrant ils ont mis leurs masques
moi j'étais dans l'eau sur scène je
voyais pas une personne d'enlever son
masque il sortait tout un parent tout le
monde écoutait les consignes et en
sortant ils se laver les mains
voilà donc j'ai qq qu' il n'y a jamais
eu un cluster dans un cinéma ou dans un
théâtre on leur ait su épier les médias
ce serait le le leur est bien relayé
donc je nous ne comprenons pas alors
vincent en taille en images vous êtes
dans le même état d'esprit en tant que
syndicat justement est-ce que vous vous
attendiez à cette annonce de jean castex
penser que le gouvernement peut être
allait annoncer une bonne nouvelle est
ce qu a eu des discussions d'ailleurs
qui ont été entamées avec les divers
syndicats d' de votre milieu
je voulais peut-être rappeler que les
10e juste riz culturelles et créatives
en france ces 94 milliards de chiffre
d'affaires si le troisième secteur
économique en france donc je pense que
tant qu'on n'aura pas compris que la
culture a un poids considérable dans cet
équilibre humains cause que l'on
souhaite tous on ne l'émeut les mettre à
part en déplorant ce qui concerne notre
librairie
elles ont été fermés en france lls sont
restées ouvertes aux états unis en
allemagne en angleterre en belgique en
suisse on a du mal à comprendre comment
au pays des lumières c'est possible
qu'on ait fermé mais libre à vie alors
très concrètement
sont elles sont réouvertes ou des sept
livres sur dix ans en france ce sont des
des objets que l'on donne donc il ya un
échange inter personnelles très très
fort au niveau du livre et donc c'est
une concentrer toutes les ventes sur
quelques semaines c'est quasiment
impossible donc il y a des livres donc
des auteurs qui passeront à la trappe
est donc faux problème il est dans tous
les secteurs
500 prenante dans tous les secteurs mais
je reviens à ma question est ce que vous
regrettez peut-être une absence de
concertation justement avec les pouvoirs
publics sur la décision qui a été
annoncée hier par le premier ministre
je pense que le gouvernement est
tétanisée par les la situation sanitaire
donc il nous est évidemment assez
difficile d apprécier ce que ce qu'elle
en ait au jour le jour
il est certain que pris isolément chacun
de nos secteurs c'est mettre en oeuvre
le protocole sanitaire qui fait qu'on ne
comprend pas très bien pourquoi ans
ferme
mais après ils ces complexes je veux pas
dire que c'est
c'est simple on ne va pas être non plus
non plus à leur place mais on voudrait
essayer de comprendre qu'est ce qu'il
faut faire et je ne vois pas très bien
le pourquoi
pourquoi on ferme à christophe alévêque
vous vous êtes un humoriste qui a une
certaine notoriété pour vous est ce que
les semaines à venir elle voit difficile
on pense aussi à tous ces professionnels
du secteur dans votre domaine
particulièrement qui sont peut-être
moins connus qui travaille aussi dans
l'ombre mais le le le problème
évidemment on est confronté à une
une pandémie on a le choix en ce moment
entre la névrose et la psychose
mais quand j'entendais hier notre
premier ministre avec son ton de
professeurs de province nous dire que la
priorité c'était la santé nous dans les
milieux artistiques et est en train de
ruiner la nôtre j'ai eu combien de
copains qui sont passés aux
antidépresseurs aux anxiolytiques
il y en a même un malheureusement qui a
commencé à faire une connerie
ces termes nous allons moralement très
très mal donc priorité à la santé et la
santé qui j'entendais encore il ya deux
jours que c'est une branche de l'onu qui
est qui ah non c'est ça qui allait avoir
en 2021 150 millions de personnes qui
allaient rentrer dans l'extrême pauvreté
je passais il est rare et public
le leu leu y avait une queue pour les
les restos du coeur mais je n'avais
jamais vu ça de ma vie
les pédiatres alerte tout le monde
les psychiatres n'en parlons pas donc
oui tout lévis val
oui on essaye de sauver des vies mais je
pense mais je ne suis pas un spécialiste
je ne suis qu un ignare
on est en train d'en sacrifier d'autres
150 millions de personnes de nouveaux
pauvres en 2021 dans le monde
safra combien de victimes ça hein
meilhan de 5 10 et ce qui aura des
compteurs le soir pour cela le justement
s'agissant des aides des pouvoirs
publics je sais pas à vincent montagne
et vous christophe alévêque si vous êtes
allé faire un tour sur le site du
ministère de la culture
c'est un site en fait qui regroupe
toutes les aides possibles pour tous les
secteurs de la culture ce que vous êtes
allé faire un tour sur ce site ou pas
nous sommes engagés non nous nous sommes
rendus en dialogue constant avec le
ministère
nous savons très bien que le ministère
est préoccupé très concrètement des
aides à apporter ensuite concerne aux
libraires aux éditeurs et aux auteurs
mais c'est évident que le les
conséquences vont bien au delà de cette
de cet arrêt économique surtout pour le
spectacle fille ils vont les et que les
théâtres les cinémas
c'est à dire que c'est pas uniquement
une question de compensation d'art
chiffre d'affaires c'est là une vraie
problématique humaine derrière viens de
lire l'histoire à l'évêque
alors justement christophe alévêque sur
le les aides de l'état vers ce secteur
de la culture tous secteurs confondus
quel bilan vous fait qu'aider mais j'ai
passé ma matinée au téléphone avec des
diffuseurs des producteurs des ddd des
directeurs de théâtre il ne faut pas que
ces aides il y en a on ne peut pas le
nier faut pas que ces aides soient un
moyen de nous faire taire j'ai senti à
un moment donné que c'était bon écoutez
on va vous était donc donc fermer là non
et comme le disait monsieur de toute
façon nous je veux dire c'est une goutte
d'eau par rapport et les retours que
j'ai vu ce matin de producteurs
diffuseurs de spectacles de directeurs
de salles c'est qu'ils ont fait des
dossiers pour certains il fallait pas
plus 12 pour les remplir
mais pour l'instant tout le monde attend
le premier euro le chômage partiel tombe
dans le reste nous attendons et la suite
ça sera quoi pour pour vous maintenant
on va attendre justement un des
confinement total pour qu'on va repartir
comment est ce que vous voyez vous
l'avenir maintenant le gros problème
c'est qu'on ne le voit pas c'est à dire
qu'on nous annonce une date maintenant
nous n'avons moi personne je n'ai plus
aucune confiance dans ce gouvernement
qui depuis le début et on a le droit
d'avoir un esprit critique
effectivement c'est une crise qui est
difficile à gérer mais pour l'instant
tout ce qu'ils ont fait je le sais très
bien puisque je fais spectacle fait une
revue de presse j'ai pris toutes les
notes possibles
tout a foiré c'est pas compliqué tout a
foiré des masses au gel au début au
déconfinement aux tests à l'application
laquelle personne ne s'est abonné voilà
donc les numéro d'autosatisfaction à 18
heures par le ministre de la santé
moi j'en ai ras-le-bol je n'écoute plus
ces gens je n'ai plus confiance
il ya quelque chose qui a été trahie et
dans notre métier il ya une vraie colère
et ils feraient bien de se méfier
est ce que visiblement la colère n'est
pas que dans notre métier voilà c'était
le lait général on l'a bien vu ces
derniers temps donc ses astuces
il faut faire attention les gens font en
train de péter les câbles comment ça va
se finir
alors justement vincent montagne est ce
que cette défiance que décrit christophe
alévêque vous la ressentez est ce que
vous êtes d'accord avec lui mais c'est à
dire que de chance sans horizon on sait
très difficile de de travailler sur un
plan de relance et donc on comprend que
ces faits complexes on m'attend défini
laksar mais on attend aussi cueilli une
vraie vision d'un plan de relance et il
vit pas de de la cosmétique qui vieillit
pour l'instant fait que beaucoup
d'acteurs de la capacité de que de
continuer à vivre dans ce métier et
chora de quasiment impossible y siégea
pas un plan adapté est pour l'instant
oui on est très loin du compte
merci beaucoup monsieur merci à
christophe alévêque heures et humoriste
et vincent montagne président de média
participations et président
du syndicat national de l'édition